both from azerbaijan so we are not too
surprised what they have played to draw
wow we've seen
what's this opening called it's called a
rangatang opening
from magnus carlsen you predicted a
king's pawn opening
we were talking about an offbeat opening
this is as offbeat as they come
i've never seen this from a top level
grandmaster in a serious event
you might just had like a huge reaction
after making it it seemed
maybe he wanted to move the pawn next to
it the english opening but
maybe maybe the pawn one square forward
rather than two squares forwards um
i i don't know it would be great if we
could actually see
if we have that recorder if we can
actually see magnus's reaction after
making that first move once again i just
want to
see if if we are okay
what do you think okay like this or was
it planned okay what's happening i mean
they've been making moves
thick and fast uh black actually
developed in the center with his own
pawn
and there has been a trade the first
pawn that white pushed the orangutan
opening that has been snapped off the
board as well but in return
magnus gaining his central pawn so a
trade of pawns already at this early
stage
magnus now attacking black's bishop
which was developed
so magnus just trying to kick that away
with the pawn i think it wasn't a mouse
slip
i think i've seen this position before
and yes magnus wouldn't have
followed up his mouse well mouselip so
quickly
if he hadn't